these children are oblivious to the
dangers which surround them in Motion's
old city their families have returned
but many areas in their neighborhood are
peppered with unexploded munitions we
had to stop Abdullah from picking up
bomblets he says our in that tub close
to where his children were playing not
far from that spot our human remains
still there two years after isil's
defeat abdullah and his sister are
looking for their father they are not
sure whether he's under custody or under
the rubble
oh yeah sir doesn't want to reveal her
identity she wants closure neighbors
told us after that our father was dead
civil defense staff might have removed
his body with other dead bodies or we
know is that how father might still be
under the rubble this graffiti warns
people that bodies are still under these
homes human remains like this can still
be found scattered in the old city of
Mosul although several defense says that
most bodies have been exhumed what I
cannot show you about this place is the
very strong stench that people in this
area have to live with it's hard to
breathe here but some residents are used
to the smell parents are concerned about
safety and the spread of disease from
decomposing corpses 800 bodies of
children have been exhumed perhaps human
rights commission wants to help ministry
to expedite DNA tests of the thousands
of recovered bodies besides closure
missing relatives means many legal
problems in Mosul from reclaiming your
house to seeking compensation for
victims of the war in Zanjeer Lee
neighborhood airmid is still looking for
his mother and sister the names on the
mural are the ones whose bodies have
been found more than 400 people went
missing in the old Pepsi Factory ISIL
snipers were shooting civilians as they
fled it got separated from his mum and
sister in the mayhem he believes they
were buried when the roads were cleared
by security forces along with others
including ISIL fighters we asked for
their lost rights and a death
certificate we can't even start the
process without the death certificate
and they won't give us one until they
have a body the bodies are now
decomposed and probably mixed with ISIL
bodies under the rubble I'm not alone
this is a collective issue
that needs to be addressed the cleanup
will take millions of dollars and the
local municipality has lost more than 70
percent of its equipment during the war
even after two years it's an
overwhelming task has become a city of
rubble we have formed a committee to
deal with the old city and it'll start
working soon to give us an inclusive
outlook for basic coordination and
finding effective mechanisms during the
intense battles in mostly small
graveyards were formed those who suspect
their relatives are under the rubble
also want proper burials and possible
closure sama Punjabi the others era the
old city of Basel